i catanji brown jackson katanji brown
jackson is changing the face of the
supreme court with her swearing in the
nine-member united states highest court
has its first female black justice and
for the first time no longer features a
majority of white men i think it's very
important obvious
for the black community why
having appointed
judge brown to the to the bench is so
important
but it's also true for i think our
country at large because it's a
statement about how far we have come for
so many years for hundreds of years
she replaces retiring liberal justice
stephen breyer so she will not alter the
court six to three conservative majority
a majority whose reliably conservative
decisions have recently called the
court's reputation for judicial fairness
into question and outraged millions of
americans
the court's recent decision to overturn
the federal right to abortion despite
half a century of precedent that the
court's recent additions promise to
respect has roiled much of the nation
with protests continuing on thursday
president biden says the court has
brought that condemnation on itself good
afternoon everyone he wants congress to
pass a new law protecting abortion
rights nationwide even if the senate has
to discard the filibuster rule that
effectively requires a 60-vote super
majority to do it the one thing that has
been destabilizing is the outrageous
behavior of the supreme court of the
united states
on overruling not only roe v wade but
essentially challenging the right to
privacy we have to change that decision
by codifying roe v wade but in issuing
its final decisions just before katanji
brown jackson was sworn in the court
handed president biden a victory
the court upheld biden's authority to
end a trump era remain in mexico policy
that required many migrants to live on
the mexican border in camps while they
waited to apply for asylum but it dealt
a blow to biden in west virginia versus
environmental protection agency in that
case the court ruled the epa had no
authority to regulate carbon emissions
at power plants because congress hadn't
given it specific permission to do so
if the court applies that same reasoning
to other federal agencies it could
significantly reduce the power of the
federal government so help me god
the face of the court may be changing
but its direction is now steadfastly
conservative criticism or not john
hendren al jazeera washington